hi everyone thanks for being on time uh
good early evening
um thank you for joining us on zoom this
evening i'm email librarian at library
at orchard so for the last month or so
library at orchard has been home to
studio sml's abstract creatures
exhibition presented by the press room
so if you haven't caught it the
exhibition will be up until the 3rd of
july there are free stickers so please
hit down if you have the chance to as
part of this running exhibition we are
happy to have this zoom panel a
beautiful life with the design studios
on the wall and forest and whale
today's session is also moderated by
none other than kelly chang of the press
room so before we begin the program just
a brief introduction uh
for the zoom functionalities uh there's
a dedicated
q a segment at the end of today's
session so please type your questions in
the q and a section that you see at the
little button at the bottom of your
screen also note that this session is
recorded and will be made available on
the design singapore youtube channel for
everyone's future viewing so without
further ado i will just hand the time to
kelly to share a little bit about studio
xml the exhibition and the panelists
you'll be hearing from today so kelly
please
thanks thanks emma okay maybe we flip to
the first slide
that's right hi everyone uh thanks for
joining us in this uh top session of
studio sml
so uh just to share a little bit studio
xml is a documentary and archiver
project that hopes to document the
journeys of local architects and
designers and review the sacrifices
struggles and rewards of being a
singaporean creative
situational talk sessions like this
hopes to promote open and candid
conversations about the design industry
our vision is to educate the general
public on design matters and nurture a
greater appreciation for the work that
designers do
the next slide
um and yes this is the exhibition that
email was sharing about it's uh called
abstract creatures it is a traveling and
art installation that serves as a
physical touch point to the website
studio xml each sculpture is actually a
metaphor for a specific design studio
capturing the personalities and
qualities of that founder
catch the show now at
orchard library which is on its last
lake after about
10 locations or so so uh do visit
orchard library before the 4th of july
and catch the show abstract creatures
and check out our studio xml website
www.studiosml.net.sg
next slide
yep this is the exhibition and then the
next one yeah
okay so without further ado
i would like to
share with you today's panelists
first of all we have on the wall and
then we have forest and will
and of course myself i'll be the
moderator for today
so
an introduction on uh on the wall or
another wall in chinese which uh
translates into a peaceful nest
uh they are a wallpaper textile and
interior design company founded in 2-0
16.
through their designs they share our
singapore stories with the world true
commissions from patek philippe hugari
and new york botanical gardens
they have also represented singapore at
london 100 design indigo brussels
singapore inside out in tokyo
without much further ado i would like to
welcome mike tay and eugene yip the
founders of on the wall to share with us
about
how they use their products and design
to create a beautiful life
hello everyone
good afternoon good evening thanks for
having us
and this topic we find um very
meaningful and uh glad that we have a
chance to share
our work and
what inspires us
so um to start off as designers in
surface print and interior
we always aim to achieve a sense of
balance
clarity
a sense of belonging
in the space that our clients live and
work and ourselves to
so um
olive oil as kelly has mentioned um in
cantonese actually means unlocked
yeah
and uh so a nested we hope that through
our work we can create a space that
inspires
brings joy
create conversations with guests and
fellow living members
reflect on our roots
as to
also connect meaningfully with others
so over the course of last six years
we've been trying to celebrate the
beauty of life by looking at aspects
of life that actually touches me
personally
as a designer um celebrating my life
as well as um and what things and places
and uh cultures that shape me into who i
am
so uh moving on uh i have the pleasure
to
share our first design one of the first
designs it's actually um chiangbaru
where we used to live for about seven
years
okay uh so over here these are few
images kind of sum up our journey there
the community
uh the pattern is very much about
the life of the community the story of a
cat that is very famous
as well as uh things
found in all corners of this
neighborhood that inspires
and uh helps us to appreciate
the beauty of life
in many ways
so on the top left corner you see bob
bob is actually a very um
special cat that belongs to the
community people who lives in the
village which we call it
everybody will know who is bob
so
bob has a facebook page and he has lots
of followers
he knows which uh house to go to to get
fed uh where to get uh pet and love by
people
so i think um where we are always
inspired and coming from is always
looking at connections
and i think that uh that's how
we appreciate a sense of beauty
and then in this case for tiong baru
then on the
uh where we live i also shared a picture
of our home interior which is on the
right side
that unit we're living at in what street
and you can see at the back is actually
a courtyard where natural light flows
through it is really indeed a beautiful
place and i'm thankful that is actually
also this place that started uh
only war um because one monday i was
just looking at
that the fact that we are having such a
beautiful time there and what actually
inspired and what just shaped and gave
us that experience
so looking at
all the corners naturally uh we are also
fond lovers of
vintage
things
like uh the window grills that you can
find in
the shop house and the walk-up units
as well as the activities
of the temple the market there
so along the way
this pattern connected many people
from customers that come in to buy
an ottoman to
commercial projects where we supply
wallpaper and fabrics
for
one of the corners for the
office as you can see in the middle top
photo
so um of course tomorrow has a lot to
offer beyond that um i also created
another pattern that posts close to many
singaporeans hearts
and and this one is actually pretty much
inspired by
the fact that on weekends uh whenever
friends are here we never fail to go and
uh
go to the back of our
our unit and there is a
shop that makes quick way pastries at
the back and sell it fresh at the front
this store their shop name is galicia
i'm sure i think some of you may realize
actually
sadly they are closing soon because
the couple have been running it for many
years and they've decided to retire
so
all these quick quiz that we share you
know we still stories it's just about
how people actually
remember fondly about
whether is it
at school
a canteen breaks or visit
like my auntie when i was young you know
she never failed to buy some quick way
in the morning especially for the family
so kway town
it is actually symbolically
not just a pattern but uh it is very
much about
love
uh
life
and as well as um
things that are simple yet means a lot
and that's where
very much
is our key
motivation in telling stories like this
so we attach a little clip a video of
gift sets that we also
offer here is a set of table runner and
coasters
moving on um there's one more
interesting print that i would like to
share with you
this is a parana gun story
it actually holds uh very close to my
heart the reason is because um
my other half of my my mom's family
actually some of them are world parana
khans and prana
how i came to realize was because
since young i've been you know always um
very close to my mom and uh helping her
with the store
so when uh she's speaking to our
customers um she spoke very good malay
and uh me and my siblings were like very
amazed and
very also very positive why how come she
can speak so good malay and uh then we
found more about you know stories about
her family her mom
and both are very strong-willed uh women
that has big love for the family
and uh so so this this pattern very much
is about them
and uh the other
special part about it is that uh it is
actually our first collaboration with uh
veronica museum
so a pattern was created to
showcase
the last exhibition before the museum
closed for renovation
it was called amig number so over here
we definitely see that there is a strong
connection
from our customers uh with the pattern
so
we have like uh fondly customers that
buy fabrics and make into
nice dresses for themselves
and on the bottom left actually this is
one of the projects with spotify as well
where we decorated part of the office
with our fabrics that tell stories of
singapore and culture
and on the right side um
from a main pattern we also lifted out
and created a pradakan spoon pattern
which was made also made into
shirts
yeah so that is also a very special
pattern that
we're happy to share
okay um the next one is uh city in the
garden
i think singapore
has really lovely
uh landscaping and
mix of
more natural parks
and uh
very um organized
and then
yeah planned uh cityscape that is uh
closely
filled with nature
and uh how this came about was that
there was a part in my life where i was
living near to botanic garden
so um
my best part of the the period there is
always in the morning walks
and
i'll bring my dogs and walk from um near
the stevens road cut through to delve
and then cut through to botanical then
make a loop come back to tangling
um orchard and then going back to
stevens again so this whole belt uh is
really lovely i mean it is also a quiet
time for me
to think and uh to
kind of be still and allow inspirations
uh to float
so
city in the garden actually captures the
greeneries the landmarks in this area
that covers like botanic gardens
the colonial shop houses
singular museum iron orchard and uh the
newton hawker center and inside there
has uh a little figure
of a guy and and and a dog and actually
there's actually me and mimei which you
see right now in the middle um bottom
photo
yeah
so attach a little clip a video of um
plate
so we do
do gifting as well this is a bone china
plate
yeah and we're happy that actually
along the way
customers not just local even expats
they are very strongly uh
i mean they connect very strongly with
this pattern so recently we have a
customer
the family has relocated back to germany
and after settling down they actually
contacted us again and
requested and they ordered a few rows of
wallpapers for different parts of their
home in germany and one of them is
actually this city in the garden
simply because i really reminded them
about their happy times in singapore and
i think that's the biggest reward for me
and uh for us
uh it's actually through
through um creating works that move
to connect and to share with people in
the community
so the last but not least um
this one talking about morning walks and
uh i've continued to
do that even though now i have moved on
to the east side
so mornings and evenings sunsets and
sunrise
i find a lot of inspiration and energy
emotionally is it's really
i mean it really works for me as well
so one of these mornings when i was
there
i was captivated by
this lovely bird called
so i find that uh
really beautiful although yeah it is in
a partially concrete jungle in a sense
but but i must say that
i think design itself
apart from
being there to serve as a function
to improve people's lives i think the
other part of it
i hope that i could
through our work we are able to
look at how to
let our work help connect
uh people with things places and nature
around us um because we believe that i
believe that design should also serve
to heal
to recharge our emotions and to make us
stronger
person
so
over here on the left side you see
a recent project where a customer
ordered
this
as wallpaper
yeah and um yeah so in the middle uh
just uh the top is actually a
shot of the
same pattern but printed on the cotton
satin
making into shirts for some customers
and below is another um nature related
uh pattern called million greens which
is also a uh i mean we are very
delighted and extremely happy that uh
when we came across the news that our
government is actually uh planning and i
believe they have started uh to look at
planting a million trees in singapore uh
to fight the um
uh yeah climate change
yeah so thank you for uh this
opportunity um this is what we are
prepared for today's
introduction thank you
thank you mike and eugene
so now we would like to
uh
introduce our second speaker for the day
forest and rail
forest and wheel is a multi-disciplinary
design collective that focuses on
products and spatial designs based on
sustainability circular systems and
future envisioning as a recipient of the
design singapore council's good design
research grant first and will develop
innovative alternative packaging to
combat wasteful takeaway boxes the
eclipse includes singapore good design
award maison a obj rising asian talents
and the red dot design award and without
much further ado i would like to pass
the virtual mic on to
wendy chua
who is one half of foreign for the
presentation today
thanks kelly for the
let me pull introduction
my slides
um everything is good
all right so i be again um
yes so when when i was given this topic
by kelly um
this quote came to mind
and um
i i think also eugene mentioned about
balance and i think beauty has a lot to
do with balance
um bruno munari is an italian design
master and he once said this that when
the objects that we use every day
and the surroundings that we live in
have become in themselves a work of art
then we shall be able to say that we
have well there's a time for that we
have achieved a balanced life and i
think that is for me what beauty is and
as a designer how
i could try to bring beauty to the daily
life
yeah so that's me um i'm currently based
in berlin doing a master's program while
i run my practice
um so
trying to figure out what what i am
as i was preparing for this talk and
well i'm a student right now i'm also a
teacher for many years
in creative pedagogies and i'm also very
interested in um
in research in general like curiosity
for for everything around us
and the kind of work that i'm currently
pursuing is interdisciplinary design
where i can look at other fields through
the lens of design
um
i'm also very interested in anthropology
and we do that a lot in our design work
which i will share more later
um creative pedagogies
craft craft whether it's in the past or
in the future
how they can continue to exist materials
and processes
and if i look back in time like how i
got to be here
perhaps along my interest in design came
from the fact that i'm the daughter of a
cintras so i grew up going to people's
park being very
used to the textures i actually grew up
in tongbaru so it was really nice to see
eugene sharing
and i'm also a third generation of a
hawker family of course i'm not hawker
but
i have helped out before when i was
young and i think that also strongly
connected me with with the hawker
culture in singapore
and now i'm part of this uh research
cluster called matters of activity where
we look at um active materials
yeah so that's a little bit of
background about me before i begin
yeah so forest and whale which i run
with my partner
busavo module
is is really about
um the kind of practice that we do um
which goes from products to spaces
but if i really have to explain it it's
about having one foot in the factory
we visit a lot of factories to do the
work that we do and having one foot in
the community because of the kind of
participatory design work that we do
yeah
and and sometimes these tools
are completely different worlds you know
we do products for companies and we go
to factories and then we also do
participatory work for communities but
sometimes they can come really
interwoven so like for this collection
we did for scientik for their japan
um
audience we actually went to japan to do
endographic studies visited their
people's homes to understand how they
live before we design the collection
so beauty for me comes in in forms i
mean partly because that's really my
training how do i create
beautiful forms
and
looking back you know this is a table
that i designed when i was still a
student
um in nus
um that was later produced by elena
rosen
and
this is a recent chair that was designed
together in collaboration with my
partners
and
it's really an evolution of the kind of
work that we've been doing over the
years in furniture design
and when i tried to think back about
that table that i first designed
i immediately think about the book that
i was very drawn to around the same time
by bruno munari where he was dissecting
what a tree is what's the anatomy of a
tree and it's really about that white
branch right every tree has the white
branch actually
and with this table we were
trying to
redesign the tripod structure which is
the most fundamental kind of
structure
by inverting one y joint over another
right and evoking the branches of a tree
but aside from pursuing such form
we find the beauty is also a lot in the
making
when i was designing this exhibition for
the centennial showcase of sorian who is
a design master from japan
i visited his studio and spoke to his
apprentice of who was with him for 27
years and he said that for soriyanagi he
believed that everything that is to be
used by hand should be formed by him so
as you can see all this tableware that
he designed
he had um
sort of a ceramic studio in his ceramic
workshop in his design studio where he
can shape every single piece um that he
was gonna design so he can actually feel
how it was being used
and i think that was also why i'm very
drawn to the beauty that is happening in
the making process not when the final
outcome is is conceived right so
over here you see that when i saw mr e
who's a machinist in jambasa lading a
piece of aluminum rod
that shavings as it's appearing is it's
so beautiful that that led us to design
a silver rose um labor pin later on but
i actually found it even more beautiful
in this very moment when it is just
peeling off the sauce material
and i guess that's how we were drawn to
documenting the kind of work that's
happening in the workshop that we
usually don't see
as well as all the different traits man
and craftsmen that was in the jambasa
auto and ship repair district
and it's not just about the makers as in
like the human
makers um
i think it's also very much about
the non-human makers so when we were
doing these rug collection for the round
maker that's based in singapore
we also went to the factory um
and understood the material and this
collection obviously is inspired by
nature
but that's when i found out that
actually most of the wool for the carpet
industry
came from new zealand like 90 of it
comes from new zealand
and there's all these different sheep
species that produce the type of wood
that's used in cupboard
and of course there's many types of
sheep species but only
merino which is at the top right um is
what we most know what most of most
consumers would know like merino wool
and simply because it's very fine it's
um very expensive so the price you know
gives it more importance that you want
to separate out the marina wool from the
rest whereas all the other wool actually
get mixed together
and those long will are used
specifically for carpet making
and i often wonder when i look at these
different types of sheep species
like these are the non-human actors that
are producing the things that we use
every day
and
maybe we should also take time to um
be grateful right for their hard work
in
producing the material that we use to
make the things that we use
a lot of the work that we do is also
about hidden beauty
like in this lamp that we designed
we started off with
crumpling a lot of paper
and shining a light on it
the topic that was given to us was what
is the spirituality of design
specifically the spirituality of asian
design we were going to bring it to
milan design week
and
it was it was such a
like
almost intangible kind of topic and so
we started to play with light because we
felt like that has a lot of spirituality
and we wanted a light that was very soft
uh we were playing with different type
of crumpled people and we stumble upon a
paper that has a reflective surface on
the inner side
and so it creates a very beautiful
effect when we are able to put a
diffuser on
yeah so this was in some ways a light
effect would not be visible um
without a play or study of materials
and this is another example of a hidden
beauty it's a new collection that we've
designed for scantiq that's launched
this year
and it really comes from the pandemic
times when people are working from home
and you see a lot this kind of
combination where dining tables become
office tables and it's no longer just a
table for males but it's also a place
for work
and you need a very very good office
chair and this office chair often have
problems just tucking in under that
table and so we spent a lot of time
actually redesigning the under structure
of the table so that the office chair
can tuck in with the armrest and these
are the details that sometimes you know
if you look at a simple table you may
not notice but for us functionally it is
a very important
detail to take care of
another example of hidden beauty this
was a material that we found in a trade
fair
if you look at the top left-hand corner
that is
actually a ceramic substrate that is
found in all the cars all the
motorcycles vehicles around you it is
found in a catalytic converter
and and
it catalyzed the reaction of
converting the carbon monoxide carbon
dioxide and usually only car mechanics
was seeded
and we found the material i thought was
actually really beautiful because it's
ceramic
and we thought what can we do with it
and whether we can turn it instead of
diffusing exhaust fumes to diffuse uh
scent
and so by shaping it um it was also very
easy to shape we were able to dye it to
the colors of the
lemongrass to create a sand diffuser and
because it's an unglazed ceramic it
actually was very very porous and very
good for absorbing scent
um i think beauty is also in the
familiar everyday life i think the word
here the key word here is familiarity
right like you can come up with new
ideas new innovation but you always need
a little bit of familiarity to
to understand
what that product is meant to do
so i'm going to show you a short video
of
us doing anagraphing with a hawker who
is a
second generation copy hawker in holland
food center
[Music]
foreign
young
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
um we were interviewing him
for this project on um ryu's lab that
that was um done through wheels that we
started last year
it began as a project when we saw all
the disposables that was created during
the pandemic
and we were of course very
um attracted to all these reused
cultures that already exist in the past
since sustainability is clearly not
not
a new concept at all in fact life was a
lot more sustainable back in the past
and we were really studying what makes
this tin really actually um good for
carrying coffee and he mentioned it a
few things himself like how the coffee
actually tastes better like he feels
that if you really care about the taste
of coffee you should take it away in
this tin of course in a present-day
context there's a lot of problems with
it it could accidentally open it has
very very sharp edges you need to know
how to use it and it's really really
hard to touch
um and so we created a updated version
of it
and i think here what we want to talk
about is how important there is
it is to think about a social connection
in a new design
and
and sometimes that that
even sustainable practice needs to have
a cultural icon that we can all be
familiar with and we can connect with
so um that project led us to think a lot
more into beauty in the comfort spirit
right because ah was telling us that
what he and his wife can retire um their
children are more or less all grown up
and working but they just enjoy going to
the kopitian uh not go down actually the
hawker center because
it is their couple
and um it started made us started to
think about how important it is all this
neighborhood coffee shop and
neighborhood hawker center is for the
communities especially the coffee shops
because that's a place that you go
very regularly
and so that's how we began a project um
that is supported by the alien
foundation that is on
bring community care into the copycam
you may have seen that as many senior
activity centers that are modded to look
like copy dumb spaces
um but still they they sometimes find it
hard to attract certain types of seniors
like some seniors do not want to step
into a senior activity center
and we find that actually a coffee shop
is a place where many seniors hang out
especially senior males
and and we see the the
increasing problem of isolated seniors
and
we thought what if we can hack
become space and reverse it by bringing
the community care into the kopita right
so we just started this project and
we're still in the early phase of ana
graphic um interviews so this is
actually them in singapore while i'm on
berlin's side in a conversation with
with them uh the one on the left is
michael
and he's the owner of the coffee shop
that we're working with and this is
actually in the community that we live
in in kabum baru where there's a very
very beautiful bird singing community
and we're also starting to understand
that how birds sing as a pastime for
seniors
is is really
a practice that helps to cross you know
cultural racial device
and to bring actually the community
together
whereas this lady at the bottom right is
the
hawker of the
data fund right the economical right
store which is so important it's really
the community kitchen for the entire
neighborhood
and she actually told us one story she
told us that when she negotiated for the
renter of her store she told michael
on the top left that she would only open
her store there if they allow her to
serve rice water to seniors because she
noticed that seniors need to take their
medication and they often like to do
that with some rice water whereas
sometimes the kopija boss may not like
that
the economical rice hawker provides such
liquids because then they don't buy
drinks right and but michael was was
very positive about it and so it was
very interesting how hawkers actually
played a role in negotiating for
some um
some like services or
or you know something like a
sort of a free service for the seniors
here for their daily life
and so that lead me to think about
beauty in community care
because this is another part of our work
when i said at the beginning that we
kind of have one foot in the community
through the kind of work that we do in
anagra in participatory design and last
year we're working closely with a care
lab from barcelona last month me for the
rainbow center and we were working on
designing services for um the graduates
of the the school for special needs
and these are some concepts they are not
real or final but
it made us think a lot about
our society today so the left side is
inspired by
a practice that was in scotland when a
group of caregivers parents of children
with a disability approach their local
starbucks and say that can we have an
inclusive hour every thursday just one
hour we'll do we just want to hang out
there with our kids
and they can be happy on their own and
we can also get to you know hang out and
share our stories
and you know if you support us then
let the other customers know that we're
going to be there and our children may
be a bit noisy but it would be you know
they would be welcome and starbucks said
okay and and that was how a very natural
community um happened and started
gathering
and made us think about how we could
bring such ideas into singapore
how we can think about what kind of jobs
persons with disabilities um can do
and and maybe that requires a
brainstorming session with companies who
are willing to provide those jobs to
brainstorm what kind of jobs um we can
create you know
and sometimes i try to bring some of
that
that beauty in
in learning from such
community projects
into the classroom
so that my students can
get a sense of it too
but it's very difficult it's very very
difficult to bring such topics without
them experiencing it themselves so this
is an exercise i do sometimes which is
an exercise on empathy
i had students who are going to design
installation in collaboration with
national museums
to
walk around the museum for a couple of
hours an entire morning actually
in the footsteps of six extreme users so
this is
obviously this student is is
masquerading as somebody who is visually
impaired so we gave him props and the
glasses only has small tiny holes that
he can look out through
and
this is a domestic worker
and a person
with disability
this is a pregnant mom
and
the female student on the right has
weights on her wrist and her ankle 2 kg
on each side so she is a senior person
with you know weighted
do that help you how tired you can be so
quickly you know
um as an older person
and this is a mom with a
with a pram i don't think you can see it
here yeah there's a mom with a pram so
she has to push the pram everywhere she
goes
and it was it was a really nice project
at the end of day some of them even
um one of them actually wrote a poem the
one that was the boy that was
masquerading as the domestic helper
wrote this poem on the right
as he sat there thinking about you know
if i am alone in singapore how much i
would miss my family back home
and some of them as you can see the
middle picture is the person in a
wheelchair and how he felt
when he's at a much lower height than
everyone else and he felt really lonely
and then suddenly the bus driver stopped
in front of him and asked him if he
wanted to board the bus but he was just
sent there on a contemplation mission
from us so he wasn't gonna abort the bus
but he was so touched that the driver
stopped to ask him
yeah so these are some experiences that
i find are also moments of beauty
and of course beauty is as we talk about
this is in the living and the living
well right having a good life but also
having a good death if you can
say
and this is a project that we have been
supporting collaborating with drama box
and arts work
for
three years while the project has been
running it's still running today
uh for more than ten years
but we were involved mainly in the
champang and
talabanga crescent installations so in
these projects
artists will go in to work with the
seniors in the neighborhood where they
touch on topics around end of life
issues
and then these installations these
design projects are done with the
community are then brought back into the
void deck spaces and we act as the
spatial designer to create um
kind of like a journey through the
neighborhood where the neighborhood is
people in the community uh uh gather for
a period of time to discuss all these
topics about end of life so these are
flowers that we place around the
neighborhood to guide them towards a
different installation and void deck
and it goes from as more as the
installation is on the pavilion to
something as big as this at teleblanka
crescent where there is a theater show
going on there is almost like a musical
theater
there is art installation at the top you
can see this little gravestone that is
done by um
three pumpkins where they are touching
on end of life issues for children so
children who have to deal with the
passing of family members
and so and so forth
and often this theater
participatory theater ends with a
discussion
where
we engage with the community
on these topics
and this project was actually brought to
venice binale as part of the singapore
pavilion and i just wanted to share some
of the and it was recently brought back
to singapore and it was just
on show in the ura center
the whole entire experience was kind of
condensed into this
uh momentum mori of um lively leaves
that would eventually wilt over two
weeks
and
visitors are encouraged to leave a
post-it note on what they think living
is and what they think dying is and
these are some of their
their comments
some of them are quite funny
you can take a look
just checking the time yeah so
all the greatest heroes die
there's a yin yang logo there and
dying is fun someone said that is not a
cycle
it's a single moment you only die once
you only live once
um
yeah
dying is a new life again
yeah it's very interesting to see what
people write
many of them are probably younger
audiences
so i think that brings me to the end of
my slides i just wanted to give you a
snapshot of what life is because the
topic is life is beautiful right not
just about beauty but life
and
currently i'm in berlin
and i'm here with my young child so
three year old and
aside from that i have to do my studies
just this last two weeks
we were in the forest
observing
tree cutting in a learning forest
and then we went to the right side as
you can see
with the professor on woodside um to
look at some of the specimens that we
got from the forest through an electron
microscopy so that was for me that was
incredible because it goes so so so so
deep actually that i think we were
looking at
a beetle so a date beetle and you can
see the feelers
and then also the top that the beautiful
video of the jellyfish that was a
trade fair that i went to recently on
robotics
and i was just sitting there for an hour
watching all these robots that were
designed
um
inspired by nature that was um
activated all around us
yeah so that's a snapshot of my life
right now and i think it's i
i think it's pretty beautiful
that's all for
thank now wendy for the very insightful
inspiring sharing uh now may i invite
also uh eugene and mike to come on so
that we can have a discussion together
okay thank you
um okay so we we do have a few questions
from the audience but uh before i attend
to their questions
uh i just want to open up this topic
about
nostalgia and heritage businesses
because it is a kind of like a common
thread between what mike was you know
how he was very inspired by uh
gyeongbaru which is you know the
nostalgia for
the neighborhood there and also about
you talked about the might you talked
about the queer shop that
you know it's there and it's closing and
all that and wendy of course you are no
stranger to heritage businesses you have
developed uh the chess set with the
craftsman
the bronze uh craftsman in the vendor
right and also some rattan pieces if i'm
not wrong so uh and also i think wendy
you had a really
interesting quote in one of your
interviews we said that the need for
local designers to balance international
materials and technology and localized
crafts and industries will be pertinent
in our next decade of
transformation i thought that is really
interesting so um i think what this
topic about life is beautiful
life is only beautiful when we have the
oh and the new but singapore is
modernizing so fast you know and we are
losing so much of our cultural heritage
and um and and since that we love like
when they were talking about how
familiarity is something that we all
love you know the sense of nostalgia
um so i i personally do lament a lot
about this lost at this rapid speed
so um i want to ask you guys like what
do you guys feel about this and also
that what
what is it that we can do as designers
to kind of bridge this um
gentrification of the city
at a rapid state
and also our love for nostalgia
so
maybe uh we'll start with mike and
eugene
i guess uh it's a reality that we are
losing a lot of uh
uh what we used to have what we used to
enjoy and cherish maybe when we were
young we didn't cherish them as much as
we do now
uh
and because of technology changes
um because the lifestyle changes we're
losing them
so i guess one way to
kind of
retain them to some degrees to
re-express them using different
materials or different forms
uh and i think that's what
mike does a lot in his work uh using
prints
patterns
to
bring back what's familiar
uh
and i i
know exactly what uh what you just said
kelly uh about how
uh you know we often lament that a lot
of things are
are gone not what we used to see in the
environment we have a uh kind of a
passion project called tape far
doing metal grills
the old style metal grills uh that were
used to be done by hand
and for a period of time we were working
on the
projects
uh re-creating old patterns uh using
actual techniques like in the
yesteryears
so i remember once when customer came to
our shop and he saw this mata grill
pattern
and he just
said he just stood there and and tried
very hard to recall where he had
seen the pattern before and
after about 10 15 minutes of
you know trying he finally realized that
that was the real pattern he saw
at his old school which is on queen
street
uh
i think it's called 222 queen street so
he he suddenly remembered that when he
was a schoolboy
uh every wednesday he had this uh
assembly on top floor of the school
building and they had to go up this
staircase and they will always see this
grill pattern on the window and that
brought back a flood of memories for him
of school days and it was really nice to
see that
someone looking at just a pattern
can feel so much of warmth and nostalgia
and kind of it brought him back to those
days when he was younger
i guess that that's one of the best ways
to
hold on to
these things that we have lost like you
said yeah
thanks fuji uh wendy
wow that's a big
topic and i don't know if there's a
solution
but i think it's also about
understanding um
i think what what uh eugene was just
sharing about
how just a simple um textural material
can
make you remember and how important
memories is like memories are to us
because basically we're living in a city
that has very little past um that
reminds us of where we grew up where we
started you know i don't even know if my
old school's still around and and that's
very disturbing right because
um i go to buenos aires it's the
entirely opposite you have restaurants
there were cafes over there from the
beginning
and the same waiter is still there
and the waiter remembers my husband who
was there as a young child you know
that's incredible like you step into a
cafe and someone can say hi to you and
say that hey i saw you grow up you know
and i think that's that's why
um for example ahua was so um
did not want to stop working as a hawker
because in the hawker center that's
where he grew up
and he feel connected there as compared
to you know if he were to retire and
just hang out at home
and and as we look at social care for
seniors i think that is really important
like that familiarity of their
neighborhoods
but also i mean in this pandemic we we
understand that
um the local is really important because
what we saw happened when the global
supply chain broke down
but also when you lose this kind of
craft what you lose is also the material
knowledge and the repairing culture
right so with our
grandparents generation they definitely
were more careful with the things that
they use because not only do they know
how to repair some of it like if they
have a broken part of their shirt um
but they are also able to descend
quality
because they know how to make some of
these things
and
and hence the consumption culture is
very different they're a lot more frugal
than we are
and so i think it's about understanding
that when we're losing
these craft culture we're not just
losing the crowd we're actually losing
material knowledge we're losing
repairing culture we're losing um this
sensitivity
to understanding how things are made and
we are then actually also
um in some ways supporting a consumption
culture that is just use and pro right
and and i think when we can draw make
the connect the dots then we can see why
it's so important to retain these crafts
but i guess the retaining part is the
tough part right like um you know
singapore is inscribed as a
poker culture
is uh inscribed in unesco but um all our
old hawkers are dying and nobody want to
continue and we have
you know foreigners taking over the
business and so i think for me that is
quite sad and kind of like you it
loses its authenticity right um i mean
because a lot of these heritage
businesses usually are sort of family
passed down and all that but um i mean
even for our pocket culture that it's
kind of like losing so this crafts
okay by the for the hawker one right i
think our government is trying to make
some of the cooking schools in singapore
like the older older hawkers are going
to teach something like that if i'm not
wrong
do you think that this the same thing
can happen with our our craftsmen you
know because like recently i i met this
return guy in kampung glam he's this old
man who makes ratan things
and he has no apprentices nobody wants
to do it and he said i i just you know i
just do until i cannot laugh you know
then
that's it and i i feel
so sad you know like
it would be lost forever you see so i
mean things like that do you think that
we can take a similar approach like
getting the polytechnic students you
know to learn from these masters or what
can we do you know what can we propagate
as designers
i think the the problem is actually very
uh
practical problems uh i mean it's a new
generation of youngsters who
may not want to go through all that
training
and
be
in a career that's going to be full of
hard work like when we were making
remaking all those
window grills upstairs and our shop
house i mean at certain point we have to
stop because uh
there's no manpower there's no not
enough space
so it's something it's a very practical
issue for singapore i mean space
manpower
um
i mean unless we
somehow have uh
we can create a hinterland where
space is cheaper where people can take
time to experiment to learn and to
create
then there is a possibility that we can
see some of this crowd
returning and interest in the crowd
returning as well
otherwise
given what we are facing in singapore
it's really really difficult
yeah so uh we have designed council
people here today hopefully
it will help us with some space and uh
maybe include some of this kind of
compulsory workshop kind of curriculum
for design students because uh they need
to use their hands right i mean
everybody just draws draw sketch up
right now
but you know we're all kind of losing
the the touch right yeah so uh yes
pollution
what do you think that we can do you
know right or maybe even uh really just
just sharing ideas of what maybe the
government can also in some ways can
help you know
yeah for sure i mean this is something
that's been on my mind for i would say a
very very very long time
because i i see a lot of my work
in documenting craft and i did that
because i was concerned that it's going
to be all gone
because when i came out as a design
student when i graduated i still could
work with so many craftsmen and then
over the next 10 years i saw them moving
from larger factories to smaller ones to
finally closing down
and nowadays with my students they
probably have to do everything online uh
through alibaba and there's something
very problematic when as a designer you
need to make things
and you're only emailing a manufacturer
and you don't get to see the processes
yourself
but
i also don't think that craft will die
off because i'm also seeing a new
generation of designers who
or artisans who basically came from
other fields they may not have been
trained in design but they decide that
they really want to do something that is
craft related
and now they want to come back to learn
so i think there's um the design
companies of you as well who then go and
be an apprentice with a master somewhere
the problem with that is that because
the craftsmen themselves they don't want
their children to be to doing to be
doing what they're doing because they
think it's tough work right so it
doesn't get passed down and then these
crafts get lost and then
10 years later someone else come and say
now i'm really interested in this and
then what you have is a gap of knowledge
and by this time when this person wants
to learn their master is gone and all
their knowledge is gone
so one possibility is to have a
repository of knowledge where we can
archive a lot of this knowledge so that
at some point in time
if someone
is ready to put aside time to learn this
you know that knowledge has been
archived software and can be can be
learned
there was something i was thinking about
another thing is how we may have to
think about how we can re-evaluate cloud
right so
for instance there's been some
scientific research that's coming out
about the decreasing
sensory
um abilities of our hands because of all
our devices and all that and you can
imagine that in certain fields like
medical field where you are being a
surgeon
and you need to be very agile with your
hands and you lose a lot of that sensory
skills and would that sensory skills be
picked up if you were to learn some
craft like sewing techniques from a
seamstress now can we make this kind of
connection
between professions that generally get
very high value in society and craft
which usually don't get that kind of
value and see that actually craft can
help us to regain some of these laws in
in sensory skills
just like how i see the
boss is actually not just selling coffee
he's actually the community manager he's
actually the one that's taking care of
the community and linking people up to
help that they may need and so if you
start to see the kobe dam as a place for
social care again the value changes
right so
yeah these are some thoughts that
i've been thinking about thanks for
sharing just to share there is a
audience member who
said
actually why must it only true police
student can have platform to promote the
skills mark okay so true enough again uh
hannah and felicia take note okay
so uh yeah so i think actually there are
many things that uh designers and also
we can work hand-in-hand with the design
counselor and all that to kind of uh you
know promote and propagate and keep some
of these uh uh crafts uh alive uh
through different means so i really hope
to see this happening because uh
watching our only few last craftsmen
dying and retiring without any uh
takers to carry on this is quite sad
yeah so okay now we have actually quite
many questions from the audience i shall
try to post them to you guys before i uh
go on and you know engage your
own questions okay the first question is
uh
to actually uh mike and jin
okay so uh
love your modern take on singapore
heritage and landscapes i've also just
read honolulu's biography on the denmark
website and was wondering
how are the responses of our singapore
heritage inspired designs on the global
market
how do you connect with global customers
with your designs thanks
so sorry the first question is how are
the
um overseas um
markets are responding to what we
created right
yes actually you know
this is one of the questions i jot down
to ask you guys like how do uh current i
mean because you guys have a retail arm
and you also sell abroad and all that so
how do foreigners respond to designs
that are very much inspired by singapore
and uh and i think that's the first part
of the question
and so second part is how do you connect
with global audience uh global consumers
with your designs that are quite uh
singapore centric
um i think first of all
the thing is that um
when we look at
international designers
very much
their motivation what they deliver
quite a few of them actually
look at what
they encounter their experience back
home
and telling their stories uh through the
work and that's how we make the design
scene
interesting um
otherwise and uh you know we kind of
like with the globalization
how technology is just um on the click
a button we actually get to see each
other's um world you know we are so
close in that sense
i think that all the more it calls for
the need to share
um our own experience our own story so
that the world is more interesting and
colorful
and going that route um indeed
we have
connected and
oversees customers in that way
also because
at one point
whether is it a stopover
or is it friends or they themselves
or colleagues they know about singapore
and uh so
they're happy to actually being able to
get to see the other side of uh
designs uh through
a more personal approach
and uh from that process discover more
about things that uh they never knew
before
for foreigners who have lived in
singapore i think
uh
they do find it heartwarming
uh they do find if they find something
familiar in one of our patterns
it will feel
it just it's a spark of joy for them so
that's that's usually the
response we get from
um
yeah from foreign customers
thank you for the answer uh next
question is
are you jin wendy what are your thoughts
on
designing just for the sake of
aesthetics or beauty
is there value in that and how would
design differ from art
in this context
or are they one and the same
good question
so um
because i thought i'll give you guys a
break but if you have something
go ahead okay you better kiv that
thought
well actually you can see in what i
shared that was pretty much a sequence
of events in my life right and you could
see that i was beginning to deviate away
from just furniture design which was
what i began with
because i also felt like is there any
value in creating another chair
but i think you always need objects in
your in your life and even if i'm using
the most sustainable material
if it's not designed with
consideration of um beauty and and how
useful you'll be in your home
you may not use it for long right so i
think that
that knowledge of um aesthetics is is
always there i think that's that's what
we bring as designers
um
design is very different from art i
think um in design we always have the
user in mind
i'm not designing something just for
myself i always have to think about
who's the audience who's going to use it
or
who is going to use this service or who
is going to be affected in terms of
community work who will be affected by a
certain design intervention
yeah so in that sense whereas i see art
sometimes as a very um it can be also a
very internal journey of the artists
right um of course there's also art
that's very engaged with the community
but
i think design is always tightly
tightly connected with the user yeah
um
just to flow on what when this is uh
this is the last point about the
difference between a design and artist i
think um half the time when i'm creating
patterns um my own stories my own
experience and i think that i hope that
this this experience that i feel
um you know i can able to pass this down
and move some people
or and let them say hey you know yeah i
mean that that's what i think uh so too
so um
indeed sometimes i find that i'm not
sure whether what i create at the end
you resonate or not um it's uh
in that way
it is so um
less stress in that sense because then i
i do it um without much kind of um
expectation
so like the recent one um if you heard
the bird singing
i mean
that's what
yeah i think that that's really
beautiful
experience and uh
you know so
of course as as what i do i can try to
control and make it more effective by
looking at the colors the shapes
as well as our
write-up which is usually uh youtube
helps in writing because sometimes
uh you know it's um i'm more visual and
putting into words is more difficult for
me and eugene does the other part yeah
so i i do think that what i do sometimes
art and design it's kind of
blurred
um but hence however if you look at art
then
artists um
[Music]
they they do face a lot of um
uncertainties
a lot of risk in that sense because what
they create is pretty much from their
own um personal perspective and whether
that piece of work that is um
you know that process of getting there
and completing it
and then putting up in a exhibition
uh and to find a voice
and to find a collect a collector
the journey is uh is far more
unique yeah and it is always like a
unique piece um
yeah unless it's a print then there's
maybe a
different copies altogether whereas
designers are yeah it's um it's kind of
different yeah competitive artists in
that in that uh aspect
thank you
i guess for designers there is always
also
a used value to what you do the
practical aspect has to be integrated
into the beauty part as well so i guess
that is
the difference between design and heart
um okay the next question is for wendy
uh dear wendy really appreciates how
your work is so informed by stories and
experiences of others
was this always something important for
you in your journey as a designer or did
it form along the way
yeah
yeah as i mentioned before i'm in design
i always say design um different from
art in the sense that it is
with the user in mind
and
and sometimes in in the design process
we are taught to think about personas
especially let's say we think about
design and marketing and communication
of a product
and i personally find personas really
difficult to work with because it's so
much of a made-up person right and and
that's why i really need to know who is
the real person i'm gonna design this
for and sometimes that person may be me
maybe someone like me who is the mother
juggling a lot of things
um but often times it requires me to do
some anagraphic interviews or to get
into the community to observe how people
live their life in order to know what
they really need
yeah and and because of this process you
will naturally gather all the stories
um that inform the work
yeah so somehow that was the process
thank you
uh okay so this uh funny question is
maybe uh
directed to hannah and phylicia
can recent retirees who wish to again be
encouraged to take up crafts
apprenticeship
so i think i think things like that uh
we really need sort of uh i think some
initiatives from the government to drive
this because i think as individual
designers maybe at best we can have to
facilitate these workshops and this
sessions but it's very hard for us as
designers individually to kind of
conduct these workshops or you know
uh bring this to a bigger platform do
you guys agree with me uh
yeah
yeah so um yeah so i i think this is a
very interesting uh food for thought
that uh that which i think which is what
talk sessions like that uh are about you
know we also want to know what the
general public thinks of design because
some of them may want to do something as
such and all that and then i think it is
uh the designers can work with design
council and maybe other government
organizations like
i don't know um to kind of make these
things happen to create platforms uh to
bring design to even a wider sort of uh
group of people who like to practice
yeah so
uh that question is actually for hana
so
uh okay more questions i think oh no
this is not a question this one is a
it's a it's a note to honor war it says
uh agreeing with honorable art is truly
problem
solving all the time
um okay so
um
actually uh wendy that there were a few
questions that
you answered in a group chat but i think
we should we should bring it up because
you know uh this is for actually general
sharing so
it asks uh when the
how do the germans sustain their high
level of craftsmanship
through the master apprenticeship
programs can we do it here
yeah um
it's an interesting question because i
think the german education system is
quite well known to have a very very
good vocational path for students who
choose not to take the university
academic route and i think what's
very good here is the societal
perception of such a pathway you know
people don't think that this is not a
good pathway or not um
not a good prospect but you know when
you go on a vocational path you just
learn from apprentice art and you can be
appreciated by society and i think that
appreciation is actually the most
important
transformation that needs to take place
in singapore with when it comes to
vocational schools
but at the same time i want to say that
craft is on a demise everywhere like in
japan in germany it's a sing i was at a
glass factory a couple of years back and
it has
it was set up 450 years ago like the
15th generation of owners and at the
time when i interviewed the owner he
told me that he hoped that his children
would take over
and
um but he will not force them and then
recently i found out that they have
closed down and i was really upset about
it because i
i thought that they have lasted 15th
generation how come they cannot last one
more but i guess the cost of things are
going up and german craftsmanship cannot
cannot be the labor cannot be cheap and
maybe they can't deal with the numbers
and they are also managing the forest
where the trees are used in the in the
furnace and to make the molds to blow
the glass so it's an entire ecosystem in
bavaria over there and
and when something can't work you know
that entire system you know just just
can't run in that same way anymore
and
yeah so
even for 450 year old factory you know
they they are dealing with the same
issues
um
there isn't really a good answer
yeah
because they don't have design culture
to support them
i guess
what's uh uh possible maybe for design
council to
promote craft as
a hobby as a passion
because if we pronounced as a livelihood
then we get very very uh
by the concept i mean i'm going to work
in this for the rest of my life but it
was crap it was crafted as something
that you can enjoy you learn
and you can create
things for yourself
not necessarily and
become a livelihood then it then we can
probably find solutions to bringing back
some of these crowds and passing on the
scales passing on with knowledge
yeah absolutely fully agree hannah and
villager taking notes there so i think
i want to touch a little bit on this
topic that uh that you know i thought we
can discuss a little bit um it's about
the sharing economy that we're in today
um when did you your copy cup the video
that we showed us which was very very
inspiring uh i understand that you are
going through a kind of kickstarter
route to get it funded
um
so i i mean kickstarter is of course
it's not a
guarantee you know you might get the
money you might not get the money if you
want to buy it
but if you really get the money it
really means that people want the
product so that's uh part one then part
two is like for uh on the wall uh you
guys have been running a retail
shop you know and online and all that
for a long time and it's not easy i know
that in singapore it's not easy you have
to pay rent and data and all that uh but
have you guys considered this uh going
through like this kick starter route
like what what do you both think of the
uh this sharing economy are we able to
as designers harness this to kind of
come up with more innovative bolder and
more experimental things
i think we we are
that definitely has crossed our mind uh
because we have
uh i mean we are always itching to to
try different things so furniture is one
area that we've been uh trying to
explore and we have some concept
uh we did think of putting it on
platforms like kickstarters to to get
orders in and then we
make them
uh which is also a more sustainable
approach to production
uh wendy how's your
cup
coming along
trying to juggle family life and all
that and and also doing this thing that
we've been saying that we'll be doing no
we are we are working on it um
yeah i think it is it's very much about
for kickstarter for designers it's very
much about bringing
the
the rights of
of production and distribution into the
hands of the designer because usually we
have to find producers who would be
willing to edit the product and then we
just earn rarities if we can make a sale
and i think what kickstarter really
allows us to do is to have this direct
connection with the consumers to be
self-producers
and to also really produce when we know
that there is demand right and
i think that's very important for us
especially because copy cup is really
um it's about social innovation it's
about having a cultural icon for
sustainable practices so if
the community feel that this could be a
cultural icon and they support it then
it makes sense for us to do it but the
community doesn't feel that way then you
know it doesn't make sense to to to just
market another product yeah and and we
truly believe in that in that little
handle which we find in many of our
packaging design in singapore and how
functional it is
um
yeah so it's a
it's definitely a great platform for us
to be able to reach out to the to the
people yeah
i don't know if i answer your question
yeah i mean yeah i i guess it's really
an open discussion but i just thought
that you know uh such kind platforms
actually can encourage more sort of
bolder and experimental
things from designers because i mean if
it's good then people will support right
you know it's called sort of like
donation kind of thing yeah so i thought
it was uh you just wanted to get your
take on it um
okay back to this q and a we have a very
warm audience today actually someone
made a comment about craftsmanship the
craftsman workshop thing it says
we need minimum wage for carson women to
succeed
but we have a question here okay thanks
so much uh wendy eugene and mike uh and
myself
uh any advice to younger designers who
plan to work in your same fields so
maybe we start with the engineering
i think to recap our journey
we both started
yeah without the relevant background
and so i think this will apply to um
not just students who are graduating but
for anybody that wants to have a career
switch
i think
we always think that uh the way that to
go
is um just be
a bit more mindful about your who you
are
uh what really draws you um motivates
you and gives you that energy to
um to wake up and to keep doing it i
think that is um that is a clear sign
that you're on beyond to something
something that makes you feel alive
um i mean when i say life i don't yeah
yeah we are living every day but
what's the moment where you feel alive i
mean that that is really a a sign that
you're on on the right path
and second thing is that um just just do
a bit more research because internet
there's so much out there whether it's
in makers
with materials grants or
we started with a um
with a small pop-up
design center
uh curated that time by farm um
yeah singapore
and
i mean that's also a
that
i feel that it's just a good way for
anyone that wants to start something and
design field
um
don't wait until everything is perfect
the sums are right the weather is good
then you you think about making the next
step yeah i feel that sometimes um
it's really about going there
doing it and then learning it along the
way and then once you press the button
the cast okay always like uses
this um this example about yeah once you
start the engine you're on the journey
you get to see a lot of people coming up
to your car hopping in going down
telling you stories telling you ideas
along the way you see sceneries you see
things and then that opens up your mind
opens up your eyes and gives you more
ideas
and um and enjoy the ride i think
definitely you have to enjoy the ride
and then by that it means that not to
overburden yourself
uh with
commitment investment
uh look at things as scalable but not
something that you need to make a lot
uh to kick start because that will add a
lot of stress you'll cloud your mind you
can't think straight and you get you get
stressed out you get beaten
and then you've got storage issues and
all that so i think it's a
it's a philosophical thing as well doing
doing this this track to understand
yourself to give yourself uh to be kind
to yourself
and give yourself some time and do a lot
of research and look at what people do
and i really love your podcast actually
thank you
yeah
i mean i i yeah i hear everybody's
stories like wow okay
you know having a
chance someone is listening to it
i mean i'm telling people that this is
such a good podcast if you want to go
know about a bit more about
who are singaporean designers
what do they do and why are they doing
all these things it's so interesting and
actually um from there you get a lot of
inspiration
and uh you you realize that actually
it's not difficult i mean it's not easy
but it is not uh not that daunting and
journey actually yeah yeah thanks man i
i agree i think actually uh from the
from the interviews that we have so far
every designer really just like just
take the plunge
and you know just feel your way along
the way you know you might fall down but
so what right then you just have to pick
yourself up yeah so that's a good advice
um wendy what's your advice
i was actually gonna wait for you to say
more as well because i wanna hear from
kelly um
yeah i
i agree with a lot of things that mike
and eugene were sharing and
i think it's i if i look back if i had
looked back and
tried to plot to where i get here i
don't think i would have gotten here you
know because i i didn't
really know where i was
gonna end up
but i know that i will put one foot in
front of the other and i know that this
is more or less in the direction i want
to go
and i think what's very important is
habits like having some kind of habits
or practice because you're never going
to
achieve something like
out of the blue i actually don't believe
in talent can i say it so controversial
i believe in in hard work i believe that
then must be conscientious uh practice i
believe that
um
as a design lecturer i believe that if i
can create certain creative pedagogies
then anyone can be creative like there's
no such thing as oh because you're so
talented so you're more creative
yeah so
if i have a very unevenness of
creativity then maybe i didn't plan my
classroom my class lesson well you know
that's how i see it
and
um yeah so in that same way and in this
way the the creative lesson or method
then is
the habit that you practice daily right
so for example
i mean singapore can be very stifling
because the society reminds you a lot
about
a lot of things that sometimes if you
look back you may think these are not so
important but somehow the society keeps
reminding you
about money about things that you need
to get and
and then you need to step up for a while
and i think that's why um right now i'm
doing my master's in berlin
and from time to time i actually plan my
year to really just be away for a while
because it really gives me clarity of
mind
of what i really want to pursue
what motivates me to wake up every day
yeah
thanks for that wendy i fully agree i
think what a lot of people do not know
is that
designers uh
work very hard and uh it's actually a
routine for us people some people think
that we just sit there and wait for
inspiration to come or whatever you know
but i mean what i have to explain to a
lot of my non-designer friends that even
there's no inspiration we have to keep
trying and try and try and try until
something comes along because if we just
sit there and they dream you know then
nothing is ever going to happen so
um i i think this is also why you know i
want to kind of like push this kind of
podcast and sessions and all that
because people have you know they have
very uh sort of unclear ideas of what
designers do they they confuse us with
artists and all that but literally they
didn't know that a lot of us uh
work like hell
and sometimes when we couldn't bring in
the money we have think of other ways
you know to to as uh when they said you
know put bread on the table whatever in
order to make things work so uh yeah so
it's really not easy and it's a lot of
hard work indeed
so uh we we have very good audience
today who stay with us for one and a
half hours uh so to close off the
session i'm just going to ask one last
question to both of you
what revolution would you hope to see in
the singapore design industry
maybe i'll start with my eugene
oh very chin
my mind goes black
i mean surely there's something you hope
that would change right
maybe i start first and probably this is
something that connects with you guys
reminded me that i was saying in an
interview and i'm hoping and i believe
it's going to be happening i don't know
if it's in that skill for uh
a localization or a local revolution
right where we can look at everything
from a more local perspective and that
that also comes from social sciences
like
there's a lot of discussion about how
climate change is such a global issue
that it makes you paralyzed like a lot
of generation z people who are the
younger generations who are very
passionate about
doing something for climate change they
actually feel very depressed that they
some of them actually think that
nothing they do will make a difference
and that is the problem when you think
in a very global way but if you can
think in a very local way then you can
see that in many small ways there are
actions that you can take and actually
it is only possible take actions in a
local manner right
and i really hope we can see that
revolution of like local materials local
craft local techniques or local
innovation or even understanding what
the singapore has around it
and
what they can bring yeah
thank you
eugene
mike well i i
uh well if you ask me five years ago
yeah i would have said oh we would hope
that
singaporeans will come to embrace local
designers
and their works
but at this point uh
i
that would have been
my my wish you know for revolution and
the design scene but today at this point
um
i i i can quite happily say that our
wish has come true
when we first started uh eighty percent
of our customer base were expects
but by year four and year five
it totally changed the other way it was
80 were singaporeans
so
thanks to a lot of efforts by the
agencies including design uh
singapore
um the awareness the appreciation of
local design designers and their works
have
grown a lot in the last five years
of course we wish for more but still
i think we have come a long way from the
time when singaporeans always think
better of overseas brands obviously
designers
um
but
i think today uh singapore's have come
around to recognizing that singapore
designers can create very good works
and very world-class works as well
so i i
i mean i'm not exactly answering a
question but i'm just
being thankful that we have
uh progressed that way
and yeah a lot of it has come a lot of
that came from government's effort and
we are really appreciative
thank you
okay so i'm going to chip in here so the
revolution i hope to see forest start is
ban free pitching
i think this is a really really bad
practice i think all designers should be
treated as professionals you will walk
into a lawyer you tell them to propose
first and see whether they want to play
or not try that go to a doctor and say
propose how you'll cut me up first then
i think about it try that go to hawker
and say this you'll hear me first before
i want to buy not try that
why are we as designers not treated
properly as professionals the moment you
step into my office i'm gonna start
charging by the hour every single
question you ask me i have a right to
charge you know totally so don't expect
us to put in two freaking weeks of work
to propose to count out to you to show
you what we can do and then you are
actually inviting like 20 people to show
you that is so not right so that is the
revolution i really hope to see
not stop not minimize but ban free
pitching okay
yeah i mean really it's about time so uh
okay with that um i really want to thank
matt eugene and wendy for today's very
lively discussion and thank you so much
for your
heartfelt and insightful sharing i had a
good time i hope all the audience had a
good time as well so thank you a lot
thank you thank you thanks kelly thank
you everybody